[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
the alex jones thing's [ __ ] it's it's
wild it's wild
here's the thing i don't i don't really
listen infowars yeah but i do listen to
him when he's on roads again i gotta be
honest with you
he's the most entertaining person in the
world i mean i hate
listen is it bad sure am i gonna get in
trouble for saying this yes
does he incite violence maybe the point
i'm making
okay the point the point i'm making
is purely forget morals forget any of
this
take yourself back to smoking weed in
the back of a car in 11th grade
yeah when you were just like things were
just funny or they weren't
they were just entertaining they it you
either watched it and went
what the [ __ ] is this i heard alex jones
okay go on a rant about
[Laughter]
demons like literal demons
for 20 minutes 20 minutes hard
about demons
and let me tell you right now i he
he started a show at night and he was
like this goes ladies and gentlemen he
goes
we are bracing this first word's out of
his mouth he goes ladies and gentlemen
we are bracing
for thermonuclear war
and i'm like how do you how do you not
yeah how do you not laugh how do you not
be entertained i mean
dude him and i think him rogan and eddie
bravo amazing we're
one of the best podcasts and i'm just
like i gotta start listening to [ __ ] and
then i turn it on i was like
what the [ __ ] this is what he does for a
living
it isn't comedy we have a theater full
of people that want to hear one thing
and you tell them that one thing that's
not it or imagine
it's bizarre it's called like it feels
like a cult how much fun would comedy be
if you just
if if you were like all right well what
am i saying i kind of do that
like i just go out and like what if they
said they just want to watch you drink
tito's
i was like wait a second wait a minute
what if people wanted to see you drunk
yeah and you got drunk what would you
just want to see you would do your shirt
wrong and tell the machine story wait
wait wait wait wait
throw me in the briar bat i would have
been i would have been a great heir
yeah like like dan bilzerian oh yeah i
love
that guy yeah yeah he's like uh he's
like a male chelsea handler right
just hot and just hot and [ __ ] lives
his life that you
watch i think most women watch chelsea's
insta stories and go like
god i want to travel with my sisters and
my niece and yeah
go to i mean all she's done is vacation
for the past year
that's what she does yeah i love it i
mean it's a great life it's
you know i mean i just don't have that
vacation right after the election or she
on her instagram she goes i was gonna
leave
the country and this is the stuff where
you go can we stop
she said i was gonna leave the country
but somebody came up to me they're like
you need to be a voice for the voiceless
and it's like number one
no one talks like that no one has ever
said number two it was your assistant
right it's like no one has ever said
that
those words i want to be a voice for the
voice like voice and then she's like so
i'm gonna stay
she was saying i don't give a [ __ ] if
anyone watches it i'm out
i'm done and here this is what i spent
my life doing here's what i think is
wrong with it
and this is my [ __ ] special and here
you go
once he put it in those terms for me i
thought about it differently
that that is pretty [ __ ] mind-blowing
and it made me think yeah what would i
do what would i say what would i
say if i didn't give a [ __ ] definitely
open with the machine
yeah yeah i can't imagine she's not
getting [ __ ] death threats from
tasmania
because she painted tasmania like a
bunch of [ __ ] savages
here's how ignorant i am this is real
this is not gonna be i could admit this
this is gonna sound embarrassing oh and
i'm gonna uh one-up it with joe list's
wife
keep going okay cause joe joe i'll be
honest with you
i had no idea tasmania was a real place
no literally i literally no i be
i i literally i had no idea and i'm
relatively smart
yeah i mean now no apparently but i
literally thought tasmanian devil
was a character on a show like i didn't
know i thought it was like one of those
places like
kind of existed but kind of didn't yeah
you know what i mean like those half
real places yeah where you're like i
guess it's around
like you know what i mean like i guess
it's somewhere and but i didn't know but
i didn't know there were
i didn't know there were roads yeah you
know i didn't know
i thought it was like kind of imagine
kind of real this is my gardener
loves uh gardening when i do a podcast
what are you going to say trump
watch he loves trump he actually he
definitely does not like trump huge
infowars fan
mike gardner hey there's joelist why
vishiya comic
sarah tolmasia really okay i listened to
something she said that made me laugh so
hard because i have said the same
[ __ ] thing
yeah and it was uh it was on her podcast
she has a podcast called vag
is this am i right about this yes okay
um
i wasn't listening to the podcast it was
a clip on her on her instagram
and uh it was she was like
i don't i don't know how chickens get or
chickens get chickens pregnant and she
was like did they lay the egg and then
the
male sits down and comes on the egg and
it's it's so funny we had that same i
was laughing so hard because
it is a thing that you would just simply
not know in this
world you just don't know it was so
funny i listened to it it was like two
clips
like two minutes long i listened to both
of them but we had it one time
we had that question at our den
breakfast table we're eating breakfast
eating eggs
and we have chickens in our backyard
where there's the poop okay
and so we just got the chickens and i
was like so wait
if we let those sit in there they turn
into into chickens if we let the eggs
sit and leon's like no they haven't been
fertilized
and isla goes how do we fertilize them
and she goes we wouldn't
a rooster would right and i was like
sweet if we had a rooster they did
leanna grow up on a farm she just she
gets it okay and so we're like wait
and leanne's like this is their egg just
like girls just like we have eggs
right and we shatter our eggs yeah this
is them shedding and isla
is in the middle of his sandwich goes
i'm eating a period sandwich and
all of us are like this is their period
that we're eating yeah and it's like
yeah
yeah by the way i you got to use that
tasmania a bit i should
you have to you have to i literally i
didn't know how stupid that made
listen there's a lot there's about 30
major cities
where you could throw out to me and you
could go is this real
or is this from lord of the rings i
thought indianapolis
i thought indianapolis was in baltimore
right
i thought indianapolis yeah this is what
you said i thought it was in baltimore
yeah
i thought it was in baltimore because it
sounds like a easter egg
right indianapolis yeah i was friends
with these black guys and we go to a
party and then
sometimes we they take over the party if
you know what i mean like they were just
like right they would just go in and
and then ultimately some white kid would
say hey
you're not supposed to be here and then
they'd be like why
and they'd be like well we don't know
you this is our party and they're like
yeah but now we're here
now my name's what now i know you and
then they'd be like no you need to get
out
and in inevitably would end up into a
fight the black guys would always win
right there's one party
that we went to and i like this happened
every time
yeah and that's why people aren't just
like let's just let them hang yeah
yeah oh woes just like every time they
were like well i guess what
i guess we're getting in a fight again
there's a certain amount of the american
public
that's mentally ill that's it a large
portion a large portion
a lot a large i've been reading my
instagram comments i mean they're
they're out there
and you're not gonna i mean we went on
that cruise together which was a lot of
fun but
you looked at some of the people on the
cruise and you went this is
a segment of humanity that is just when
they get in the voting booth the idea
that they can even
make it to the booth yeah pull the lever
and get home to their house is amazing
forget who they're voting for
yeah forget why the idea that they know
it's on a tuesday
and they go is amazing well the one time
i did do something for the school
was nice i may know i made my daughter's
uh teacher cry
oh what'd you do uh it sounds weird now
that i because i sound like a a permit
paddy
yes yeah like i do sound like that kind
of person called the cops on a black kid
in your children's
class no she was white thank god uh
right but the teacher pulled in
i was doing safety valet where you
helped get the kids out of the car
safely in the parking lot safely and
then get them on
get them on campus so you like open how
far away is this
it's it's right there it's it's right
there it's like right on campus
it's like teachers parking lot but
parents pull through the teachers
parking lot and drop their kids off
now you can let them do it willy-nilly
and it'll be chaos or you can have
someone like me with a loud voice
standing there and going
line up like come pull all the way
forward pull all the way forward
open the door and go hey buddy uh and
then yeah yeah and then
thank you and the parent knows their kid
is god in there right safely
um and part of the rules are you can't
park in the
no one can park in the handicapped spots
and no one can double park
because once you double park then it
starts to become a traffic jam in there
and then you have kids running around
and it just is chaos
right teacher flies in flies in pulls
into the
uh handicapped spot and we do have
handicapped parents
two of which were in my daughter's class
right parents uh one was in a car
accident one had a
spinal problem go wrong okay pulls in
and starts unloading her stuff and i go
hey
you gotta move that sh you can't move
that right now and she's like i light
her up quick like
yeah get back in your car and move that
she's like no no i'm a teacher i go i
don't give a [ __ ] what you are i didn't
say [ __ ] but i don't give a damn
you get in your you're not handicapped
get back in your car and move your car
she goes i'm i can park here i'm a
teacher i go no you can't unless you're
handicapped
you can't park in that spot and then she
goes oh my god
start your day off in a better mood why
don't you i said i was in a great mood
until you broke the law so get back in
your car and move it she goes
i will tell miss gomez on you and i went
tell me that's the principle i go thomas
gomez my name is bert kreiser
tell her bert chrysler sent you in here
and that you parked in a handicapped
spot
and she was like i will i said do it and
send her out to me
and in the process another woman double
parks
and i go you can't park there ma'am
you're gonna have to move your car and
she goes
oh my gosh you're in such a bad mood and
i go i'm in a great mood
but you're breaking the rules and you're
putting children's lives in danger
you're not above the life of one of
these children my job is to protect
these children
you took this more seriously than i've
you've been more serious about this in
any
way this is amazing the kids in the
cages is like whatever hey but this is
like don't [ __ ] park
dude i'm a rule follower
yeah because i i don't like lines cause
they because i'm a rule follower yeah
yeah yeah yeah and i but
we've also talked about this on the
podcast yeah so i'm calling myself out i
also feel like rules don't apply to me
sometimes
so but i'm a rule follower and so
she gets upset with me yeah and i go no
i said i'll tell you what
go walk into mrs gomez and tell her you
double park because you're a teacher by
the
way
she wasn't a teacher she was a teacher's
aide right so ms gomez comes out
and and by the way two teachers had
yelled at both two parents
had yelled at both of these women for
breaking the rules because the parents
are forced to follow the rules they get
it right
ms gomez comes out and says um okay
i have two teachers in my office crying
saying you sent them to me i said i did
she was okay we need to follow find like
a
like a way a workaround for this i said
well let me let me ask you a question
what are the rules can anyone park in a
handicap spot in double park
she goes well no obviously not i said so
then who can she goes well it's case by
case i go no it's not
it's either all or nothing i can't go oh
i'm sorry who are you what's your resume
okay you can park there right
what if what if one of the uh i said the
parent's name who's handicapped
i said what if he had walked up pulled
up where was he supposed to park was he
supposed to park down the street where
she should have parked
and then walk his child with his
crutches
get his child here i said is that how it
works and now the teachers are coming
out and they're both crying
and they were like you're just so rude i
said no
you guys broke the rules i was telling
you what the rules were and you didn't
like the way i was telling you the rules
and i said and i said i said this is my
favorite thing i've ever said to anyone
i said listen ladies i'll tell you what
it is so much easier for me to not care
than to get you to care so i'm done i'll
never do anything for the school ever
again
congratulations this is how you welcome
parents that are trying to help
and they all were like whoa whoa that's
not what we're saying i don't know
that's exactly what you're saying
i said i will never do a thing and i'll
tell you what i'm gonna go up in front
of the
what our pta thing is and i'm gonna tell
the parents not to help
because people like you undermine good
parents who are just trying to keep
children safe
and they were like okay hold on hold on
one second i went no there's not any
holding on one second my name's bert
christopher my wife's lee ann
christopher
my wife and they know my wife i know my
wife does everything for the school
and we are done we are done and we're
getting our friends to stop
because of this and i go and don't and i
have nothing but free time
and they were like okay okay hold on and
they're like we'll move our cars and i
go
one night i decided not to argue and
just to
sit back and let her talk yeah and she
um it was almost like she swung herself
out
and she ended up crying and she ended up
uh
talking about an attempted suicide wow
and
which was even [ __ ] ten times more
hilarious i know you're not supposed to
make fun of me no it's
very funny but she tried to kill herself
by jumping off a cliff
she never jumped so she didn't really
like right like i was like she said
that's
when sightseeing yeah exactly you went
[Music]
[Music]
hiking
just the wrong way